I can't spell either yeah anyway alright
thanks for the thanks for the chance to
come speak I'll tell you about some of
these things this is based on joint work
with my students Hong Nam going and I'm
on scene huh all right so let me just
jump in so so the motivation for my talk
is that we do not want machine learned
or statistically modeled systems to fail
as soon as they get in the real world
okay well you make this a little bit
more salient perhaps this is the first
challenge in the talk and that challenge
is that liking curly fries on Facebook
reveals your high IQ okay and to me I
mean there are so many problems with
this first is that there were
researchers who did this and actually
published it as though this could
possibly be true right second is that
wired picked it up and the third is they
clearly this I mean is this going to be
true tomorrow is this going to be true
with any different distribution of
people than the people they picked right
and and and even more important that who
doesn't like curly fries so it's really
way dentally I don't know it's
completely unclear to me how this could
possibly be discriminative anyway so so
you know you change the distribution a
little bit there's no way this remains
true tomorrow right you know more real
challenges you know there certainly
changes in environment that we're going
to see you right like we have Google
cars self-driving themselves all around
in California in Nevada right and then
you go to Ann Arbor in April and it
looks a little bit different right you
know these are not the same environment
right there's a third challenge that we
face all the time right I mean and and
many of us have seen this right we have
these these complex deep neural network
models and starting with work by ian
Goodfellow and colleagues you can add a
tiny amount of perturbation
imperceptible to our eyes and you can
change these networks from predicting
say that this is a picture of a panda
with reasonably high confidence say 50%
higher and now it's a picture of a
monkey
okay so this is a monkey and this is a
panda and if you guys can't tell the
difference between them then you're not
as good as the neural network clearly
right I mean and and perhaps more more
of a real issue and this is something
that my colleague Dan Binet works on I
mean we could put a transparent film on
a stop sign you and I couldn't even see
this and it could change computer vision
system so that it doesn't even see the
stop sign sees it as air right that's
gonna be a problem for your self-driving
car okay so that these things are going
to really happen in the real world okay
so I'm going to sort of look at look at
problems like around these and and just
to just to set the stage sort of put
this on a little bit more mathematical
footing let me start by describing the
types of problems that we're gonna look
at so sorry ignore this bottom part I
temporarily but what we're going to be
looking at is stochastic optimization
problems where we have some loss
function l and we have a risk R R is the
risk of our decision vector theta or
whatever our parameter something like
this and we get there's some randomness
in Z this is the environment or a random
sample or something like that we have
our loss function as a function of theta
and Z and our parameter space is some
non empty closed convex set and
typically we observe some data sample Zi
drawn iid from some distribution p 0 for
I equals 1 through n typically we solve
something like empirical risk
minimization which is we average our
loss over our data choose our parameter
to minimize that
okay so we're certainly all familiar
with this and but you and you did a
really nice job this morning setting up
distributional robustness which is going
to be kind of the framework that I'm
going to spend for the rest of this talk
so this one is spelled correctly that's
good so so typically you know we have
the classical risk just the expected
loss of our decision vector and what
we're going to replace this with is some
sort of worst-case notion of risk where
instead of just the average loss we look
at a worst-case notion of our expected
loss over some family script P some set
of some uncertainty set some family of
distributions okay and different choices
of uncertainty sets yield vary
different behaviors and some of them we
can actually certify that our parameter
that we've learned or our algorithm will
actually have good future performance
okay and that's what I'm going to try to
describe today two ways we do that so
I'm gonna give Alan sorry I should I
should mention there's been tons of work
on this in the optimization literature
and you described a lot of these papers
you know this was one of the first ones
with his was Eric your student yeah his
student Eric and then others have done a
lot of things since then so I'm gonna
give two vignettes sort of showing some
interesting aspects of this
distributional approach and their
connections with statistics okay any
questions all right so so the first
vignette I'm gonna talk about say say
trying to regularize a learning problem
by the variance of our losses so so any
learning algorithm I mean if you've
taken your basic statistics class you
know there's a bias and a variance right
or we can sometimes call this
approximation error and estimation error
and what that what that ends up looking
like is that you know you can apply your
favorite concentration inequalities but
basically the true risk of any decision
any parameter vectors data is upper
bounded by your empirical risk we can
call that our bias or our estimation
here plus something like the variance or
a square root of the variance over n
plus some term which is looks like one
on n all right and this happens with
extremely high probability all right so
so then you say well if this is if this
is true for all theta why don't I just
trade between these this this bias and
variance automatically and minimize the
sum of these two quantities right that'd
be pretty good then we're going to get a
certificate that we're within one on n
of whatever we get out of this seems
like a reasonable idea right okay we
could do that we would certify that
we're gonna have good future performance
everybody would be happy here's a
picture of the variance of the absolute
value of theta minus X and I think most
of us would agree that that doesn't look
very convex right I mean it's fun
convex kind of and then it bumps up here
and it flattens out so so the problem is
that the variance is actually while
non-convex all right so that's a little
bit of an issue so so so what are we
gonna do here what we're going to do is
try to be sort of distributionally
robust and approximate this in a nice
way okay so let's look at this so
typically you know we said we're gonna
solve the empirical risk minimization
problem now what we're going to do is
look at some kind of weighting of these
losses where this set script P is going
to be an appropriately chosen set of
vectors all right
so so so what we're going to do is
carefully choose this set P to give us
good desired behavior okay so so right
now what I'm going to choose is for a
set of uncertainty sets we're going to
choose all distributions P that have a
distance and I'll describe this distance
shortly from the empirical distribution
that goes down as something like Rho
which is some specified tolerance you
have divided by n okay and for our
district for our divergence we'll use
what's known as the chi-squared
divergence so that's just the integral
of the likelihood ratio between P and Q
minus 1 squared okay all right so then
what we're going to do is define and
then optimize what I will call the
empirical likelihood upper confidence
bounds so this is a conference bound on
what the true risk should be by just
maximizing our weights over this set
okay all right and this is nice because
one I mean you can see this is going to
be a convex optimization problem because
it's the maximum of a bunch of convex
functions and it turns out that in a
paper that Hong and I worked out last
year there are efficient solution
methods for this so you can actually
Devine define efficient sampling schemes
and solve this using stochastic gradient
type methods very quickly I'm not going
to talk about this today I'll talk about
more of the statistical aspects but you
can solve it essentially in the same
time as you can solve just the empirical
risk minimization problem up to a log n
factor yeah
yeah so well we'll talk about that soon
but so that so my uncertainty set so so
this choice of chi-squared divergence
means that the distributions P that I
could possibly choose here have to have
the same support as my empirical
distribution so I can't change the
support all I can do now all I'm doing
now is just reweighed in a not entirely
stupid way basically okay but yeah good
question we'll talk later about changing
the support and actually expanding our
distributions but for now just rewedding
is all we're gonna do but the neat thing
is that if we assume that our loss is
bounded over the set of parameter
vectors that we're looking at then
basically and this is there's no
probabilities in here at all this is
just a true statement this robust risk
is equal to the empirical average plus
square root of 2 Rho that was our sort
of robustness tolerance times the
empirical variance over n plus an error
term which looks like Rho over N where
Rho is our sort of robustness parameter
all right so this is basically says that
this is a quite a good approximation to
variance so then we just simply choose
our parameter to minimize this quantity
all right so then so then once you've
got this well then you can apply your
favorite empirical process theory or
convergence guarantees or whatever you
want and you can prove some fun theorems
right so if if you assume your parameter
space is compact and your losses are
Lipschitz or something like that well
then at least for sort of high enough
robustness levels then with extremely
high probability basically your true
risk is upper bounded by the best
possible risk plus some kind of variance
penalty so you somehow optimally
trade-off between this bias and variance
in a very natural way by just putting in
this little bit of distributional
robustness all right so let me so this
is now we've gone through some of the
theoretical results here I haven't told
you how to prove them or anything
they're not the world's most
sophisticated things but I'd like to
talk a little bit about how this
actually works in practice right so so
let's talk about
let me give an example of this so what
I'm what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at an experiment with the Reuters
corpus which is a set of news articles
from the Reuters news service and each
article has a number of labels and they
can either be about corporations
economics the government or markets okay
and so how we're going to do this is
we're gonna have data coming in pairs X
Y where X is a d-dimensional vector
represents the document and Y is a
vector of 4 plus minus 1 labels because
a news article can be about multiple
different topics okay and so we're gonna
minimize the logistic loss on this
subject to some l1 constraints on our
parameters all right so this is a 40 to
40 thousand dimensional problem with
800,000 samples okay
so intuitively what we might expect good
question what yeah that's a that's a
mistake
what we're doing is we just look at the
average loss so we look at some from J
equals 1 up to 4 of the individual Y's
you get a minus YJ X transposed data
is that that's what it actually is yes
sorry okay good question so so what do
we might what we might expect from this
actually is that if we if you think
about these the this problem you know so
there's each each sorry each category
has fairly different kind of numbers of
articles associated to it okay so if
we're regularizing the variance of our
predictions we might expect that you
know somehow we should try to equalize
performance across all of these right if
you were just doing straight up
minimizing the average loss then you
might sacrifice performance say in the
rare classes for a better performance in
the more common classes because we
wouldn't care we just want best average
performance but if we're penalizing the
variance well having bad performance
something rarely is going to increase
our variance disproportionately and okay
let's punt on that but this this
actually shows that that is exactly what
happens okay let me give a plot what can
see this a little bit better so what I'm
plotting here is what I'll call the so
so if you recall economics is the rarest
category so what I'm plotting here the
vertical axis is the recall the
proportion of times that a document is
economics and we correctly label it as
being about economics and this penalty
here is our robustness penalty and what
you see is that just zero robustness no
regularization by variance we get the
economics category right about seventy
percent of the time or 68 and as we bump
up the regularization we're starting to
get it right about 80 percent of the
time okay so we go from 68 to 80 so
about a 10% increase in performance and
there's really no degradation actually
in the performance on the other classes
you are right you are essentially doing
what I said
okay and then this just plots the
confidence bound so so we actually do
certify that we'll have good performance
although our certificates are a bit
conservative right so this is what we
print this is an upper bound we
guarantee that we will have and this is
the true risk of our predictor as we
increase the robustness penalty but we
are seeing kind of regularization by
variance and you are certifying good
performance
all right so let me let me now switch
gears a little bit how do they look I
didn't look at the weights I mean it's
like a two hundred thousand dimensional
problems so I wasn't doing a whole lot
of digging into it but I probably could
but I don't know what they look like at
all yeah all right so let me give a
second vignette now and talk a little
bit about a slightly different way of
doing robustness so so we're going to
now actually start looking at changing
the distribution of the data changing
its support even all right so so I said
earlier we don't want machine learning
systems to fail when they get into the
real world and I think I want to be a
little more aggressive than that I think
actually and I mean you know probably
very few of us are working on
self-driving cars but it is
irresponsible to release systems into
the real world whose robustness we don't
understand
right I mean I have this nightmare where
it's like you know John du chí said this
self-driving car was safe and then it
drove through a school bus full of
children right that would be bad
hopefully that won't happen but you know
so I I think it's it proves us to sort
of try to understand robustness a little
bit more carefully and how this applies
to different learning algorithms so you
know these are the challenges that we're
working with right that that this
changes this kind of perturbation
changes this from a panda to a given and
we have to drive in multiple
environments so so the type of
robustness I want to start by thinking
about looking at is you know one idea
might be okay instead of looking at our
law cell let's just look at worst-case
perturbations of our loss so we have our
data Z we perturb it a little bit in
some small ball around the data okay
whatever our loss is and this seems like
a reasonable idea and if we could do
this it would be great and certainly
many folks have looked at this so you in
Goodfellow my colleague Percy Liang and
his student Robin others
madres looked at it is he here a year I
don't know if he's here okay well madres
looked at it too you know so there's a
bunch of sort of heuristics for solving
this and more advanced ideas based on
this idea of looking at a worst-case
perturbation of individual losses now
there's this minor issue that
usually this is np-hard and in a neural
network you know these systems where we
actually do classification it is
honestly np-hard to compute these
alright it actually is np-hard to
compute these right so that seems I mean
if something's actually np-hard to
compute the robust loss it suggests to
me it's probably gonna be tough to
certify that it'll be good to you know
adversarial perturbations alright so so
this is maybe not going to quite work so
how can we figure out how to change the
distribution the right way to actually
get robustness and do this also
computationally efficiently so so the
way to do this we're going to do this
via what are gonna as Vossler stein
distances or we're gonna base our ideas
on Bostitch 9 distances so so for any
cost function c which is basically just
any function on Z cross Z or data space
to the reals the foster stein distance
or the transport distance is the
basically well let's just draw a picture
because it'll be a little bit clearer
it's the informal coupling between the
distributions P and Q meaning I look at
the best possible Mart Joint
Distribution joint measure over z1 and
z2
such that M has P and Q as its marginal
distributions but the best way to think
about this is I have a distribution P I
have a distribution Q and I ask what's
the most efficient way to move mass from
P into Q okay so we can look at we can
define a distance in terms of this sort
of earthmovers distance or boss cosine
distance and then we're going to just
look at distributionally robust risks
now where this set script P is a Vossler
stein ball around some basic base
distribution all right so so this
actually allows us to change the support
of our distribution at least a little
bit and might allow us to get some
robustness now this has been studied in
the robust optimization literature in
simpler cases like I don't know support
vector machines logistic regression
there's a minor issue that often this is
still actually np-hard
whoops all right so we we continue to
need work we still we remain in search
of solutions all right so so here's a
simple insight and now we're moving
departing the realm of like actually
really nailing this to being slightly
heuristic but we are still going to be
able to give certificates
so if our loss function LF theta Z is
actually smooth in Z sort of the data
we're observing then life gets a little
bit easier because for any large enough
lambda this function there's a premium
over Delta perturbations to our data Z
minus this quadratic is efficient to
compute right because this becomes a
strongly concave function as soon as
lambda is big enough so we can actually
compute this efficiently and then once
we have this I mean this is a trivial
observation but as soon as we have this
then well it turns out there's a nice
duality between worst case foster Stein
risks and these kinds of perturbations
using a negative cost function and
that's this theorem so for any
distribution on on Z and any cost
function lower semi continuous cost but
let's punt on that basically the worst
case foster Stein distance is actually
the infimum over all lambda greater than
equal to 0 of the expected sort of
robust if I'd loss plus lambda times Rho
so you can just do a duality calculation
you're gonna get that to pop out and so
now if you go back to this previous
slide here's our loss all we have to do
is compute this guy at least for a large
lambda okay so our idea is just we're
gonna ignore that infimum pick a big
enough lambda and then we're gonna just
solve minimize the expected robust loss
and we can actually compute this and as
long as the loss itself is smooth in the
data we're in good shape and and so you
know we can do stochastic gradient
descent for these things this is fairly
easy we just draw a data point from our
distribution approximately maximize this
and then update using gradient descent
you know this converges with all the
usual convergence guarantees if your
convex it converges if the loss is non
convex it finds stationary points
everything still kind of goes through in
the same ways all right
maybe it exactly like a gun is it
exactly like again I don't think it's
exactly like again I mean I don't know
exactly what the connections are going
to be so I'm not 100% sure but yeah so
the question is why can't I optimize
over lambda because I wanted to take
this in from the reason I can't I need
lambda to be big enough so that I can
actually compute this worst-case
perturbation okay so I need to have
lambda big enough so that I can actually
compute these perturbations to make this
easy and computationally efficient
because if it's small then again it
becomes empty hard so we can't give sort
of arbitrary levels of robustness we can
give some levels of robustness and so
you can basically again using duality we
can show that if you if you get this
basically with high probability for any
parameter in our parameter space and
uniformly in all possible robustness
levels that the expected sort of robust
foster Styne loss is upper bounded by
our empirical loss plus this little
penalty all right
and so you could also estimate it you
can actually estimate how robust you are
by computing these worst-case
perturbations and then just taking their
average then you can basically come up
with certificates that you will be
robust or perturbations this large all
right so so the theory is is kind of fun
but you know we actually did implement
these things and see if they work and
then we've diddled around and we did
some fun stuff so let me let me give
some examples of this so so basically
okay so so what's the first part of this
so typically we run a neural network I
mean 10 you showed us a bunch of them
where we have hard are basically soft
threshold inquiry in the network right
rectified linear units things like that
these are not smooth they're not
differentiable so we're gonna replace
them with some kind of smooth
approximation so we can actually run our
code and actually implement these
methods and we're gonna see what happens
so some of this is basically reading tea
leaves so you should just take it with a
grain of salt but just to give some
picture of what's going on so here this
is a trivial classification problem I'm
just saying the label y is equal to the
sign of the two norm of
- square root - okay so I have a
positive class in a negative class or
maybe it's negative and positive or
whatever okay and I'm plotting the
decision boundaries that each possible
classifier learns so this is empirical
risk minimization it's a good classifier
but it's kind of goofy-looking this is a
heuristic method for getting robustness
and then this is our sort of posture
Stein robust method and you can see I
mean again this is reading tea leaves
but this looks nice and circular it's
far away from both edges which is kind
of what you would hope to see all right
but we can also give real results so
here's here our Purdue but here's sorry
here's classification error on M NIST
and I have actually a non-convex problem
so it's three convolutional layer neural
network fully connected logistic loss on
the top and I'm plotting our error as a
function of how much perturbation were
allowing an adversary to make to our
input examples and each of these plots
is a different fitting method so the
black line is empirical risk
minimization you can see it's pretty
crappy very quickly it has essentially a
hundred percent errors and these are
some other methods with this is what's
known as the fast gradient method so you
just do one gradient based perturbation
this is another iterative method that
folks have used and then this is this
robustness method based on boster stein
kind of certificates and you can see
there is a gap here so there really is
better behavior for different for even
more adversarial things naughty right so
you're asking so the question is what's
the actual attack we're using yeah so so
we did this with four or five five
different attacks and the plot always
looks the same no matter what attack we
use so one attack is just using you put
a negative quadratic on it and you
perturb it as much as you're allowed so
that's basically the boss there's nine
attack one is good fellows fast gradient
fast sine gradient method attack one is
projected gradient descent just
heuristic Lee on your non convex
objective and the fourth one is the
iterated fast gradient sine method
all of these are efficient algorithms
how much yes I have no idea I don't know
what all white-box attacks yeah these
are all white box attacks I mean with
the the Vassar Stein attack we know
we're getting it exactly because we've
set the lambda penalty large enough that
the actual problem is concave so we can
maximize but you know and that's a
certain level of robustness but I can't
guarantee that we're getting the
worst-case attack I mean we're using we
used all the attacks not all because
there's like hundreds of them but we
used five of the common attacks we found
in the literature and this plot was
basically identical for all of them I
don't know if you have suggestions for
other things to run I'm happy to do them
yeah so that's possible we're robust
against efficient attacks but I don't
know that seems like a hard thing to
show yes no this is this theorem right
here is that we actually have basically
for any level row of perturbations
you're willing to allow in the
underlying distribution we will have
error no worse than this question you
can
just to really catch that number and the
see what's the deputy like number and
also that yeah so we could get that gap
and I don't have that plot right now so
I don't know what exactly it is all
right and I mean this is a different
this is a different attack and you can
see the plot looks exactly the same so
now we can go back to so these were
actually this is actually real data
let's go back to reading tea leaves
again we can ask okay what did the
perturbations look like that give us
actually get us confused alright so this
is an 8 this is the original image that
we classify is an 8 if you have a
network fit by empirical risk
minimization this is the 8 where it
starts to classify things as a 3 ok that
looks like an 8 to me this is another
method this this is the image where it
starts to classify this 8 is a 3 this is
a particular iterated fast gradient
method this is mod Riis projected
gradient method and this is where our
method gets confused and starts to think
this is a 3 I mean again this is reading
tea leaves but to me that looks like a 3
that almost looks like a 3 and the rest
of them all look like eights so at least
you know heuristic aliy from a human
vision perspective this looks a lot
better than things before all right I
can show you some funny plots where we
did some reinforcement learning where we
changed the gravity of different
pendulum balancing things but I think
there's a reception now Sep tells me I
have 2 minutes is there beer at the
reception who's an organizer is anybody
know if there's beer Steve says all
right there's always beer let's call it
a day let's go drink all right thanks
for your attention
happy to take some questions
[Applause]
so it definitely like see cleanup
stabbings like you wouldn't say that
it's like sufficiently Gaussian in which
like the perturbed objective which is
moist out to say the standard l2
recommendation at all yeah so the
question is are there situations where
different robust objectives boil down to
types of regularization we know and the
answer is more or less yes if you have
like a standard linear model like an SVM
or a logistic regression or something
like that then a lot of these vas return
robustness things end up becoming
regularization classical regularization
so and that's that's fahan e and kuhn I
think is that right in you yeah so
that's that's some work by these two
guys where are they I forget where but
anyway
Zurich yeah so yeah so there are
situations in simple cases where that is
that is exactly what happens oh that's
when the the problem is like SVM when
your loss is like the hinge loss or
logistic loss or something like that
then these reduce then this boster stein
robustness reduces to classical
regularization techniques but we can you
can't apply this in more complex non
convex models and you'll get a
certificate out of some sort but we have
no idea what that actually looks like
yeah
[Music]
so okay so that's that so there are two
issues here right so so one is when you
actually apply this thing and actually
get classifications out and one is when
you look at the loss function okay so
our loss function as long as the loss
function is smooth in the data then this
theorem will apply so even even with
these deep networks if you replace the
if you have sort of smooth
nonlinearities then these theorems still
apply and you're in good shape now when
you actually run classification schemes
of course it's just zero or one you
predict it or you didn't predict and so
then now this gets into a question of
when is one and when is sort of this you
know loss that you're using an
appropriate surrogate for a zero one
loss and that's a harder question
[Music]
right well I mean so okay so I should
have a plot that also addresses this
exactly what you said but roughly I mean
this this is sort of doing the inverse
of that this is asking how far do we
have to perturb this image to become
more confident that it's a three than an
eight and so you can see from this that
you know as we have more careful
robustness you really have to start
perturbing this to look like a 3/4 well
so so so the adversary knows the network
and so it's basically a white box attack
so they have slightly different paths it
picks the worst thing for the particular
network you have yes the attack is the
Boston attack
no I can give an example of that
so take the function - absolute value of
X looks like this I don't care how big a
quadratic you add to that it will never
be convex but that is a 1 Lipschitz
function yeah so we really so smoothness
is essential for this if we don't have
smoothness where monkeyed we're totally
like I said if we if we actually ran
this with values I have said nothing so
not in our current results because the
Infinity norm squared will never be
strongly convex and so you can never
actually make that function concave you
could use like P norms for P less than 2
and it'd be ok but for P greater than 2
it'll be your gonna have problems
basically yeah
[Applause]